[Musica]
non è batman rosi galli bella di terzi
per gli ultimi sono io sono fan di j
oggi siamo tornati su ferdi 13 il
permetto di fare questa intro
velocemente perché l'ultima volta che ho
giocato a sta roba qua non son riuscito
a fare un cazzo esolo to stesse ndaw una
ragazza [ __ ] negli horror non mori per
prima perché se no guts che gli
spettatori stanno fino alla fine uno
come me che un maschio e muore subito
quindi ti faccio vedere come si resiste
in un horror accendo un cero in chiesa
ti prego ma a farmi fare jason ceo
appena pregato gesù di farmi fare la
parte di un killer
grazie gesù gesù non mi ha dato gesù ama
mi ha dato un bel culo con una bella
tuta che secondo me è un sacco comoda
[Musica]
hai visto hai visto come si sopravvive
il segreto tesoro entrare in partita
cazzuti che così gli altri si cagano
addosso jason compreso è la partita è
finita la cena non l'ho messa io non
l'ho messo te lo giuro
la messa al gioco e non ho guardata
mischi che schifo le donne jason jason
vi prego jason maraffa incollo è sempre
questa non è che ti cade addosso
un'altra volta e vinciamo a prescindere
comunque raga io ho visto che mi dovrei
informare bellas animazione li ha aperto
la porta
non ho pagato di strisce i consigli che
mi avete dato quindi non so come vincere
a questo gioco dobbiamo pregare gesù
allora ho la macchina la macchina
l'ultima volta ragazzi che ho giocato a
sta roba c'era una tipa come gli scappò
porca eva lercia prati aiuto aiuto a
questa porta open open disfa kindle
please aimi tu sei mai o sei fuori
perché lei ei my name is fabio roma
sibari e your capitare a chi fa beccare
il fa ben calcato l'aveva fatto
malissimo
e cazzo linea lesbica
ahia questo ha fatto malissimo secondo
me ragazzi beh un po meglio del solito
c'è il meglio di quanto pensassi anyway
i miei compagni invece aiutarmi e ridono
delle mie disgrazie pezzi di merda
stavolta invece lorca vacca ma datemi un
maschio ogni tanto no scherzo va bene
così come si chiama sta roba
schifani fa poca gare stakhovsky faust
scappiamo nella ski faus
magari non facciamoci prendere da jason
stavolta che dite mai come cacciari
mazza jason visto che ci sono le armi
sto gioco di servono a qualcosa non
emettono per bellezza scusatemi un motor
boat c'è anche una barca da facciamo che
vado dagli altri prima vediamo cosa
fanno gli altri io li segue visto che
visto gioco ancora non ho capito mesi
come si fanno le cose meglio evitare di
far cagate non dovevano gli altri se
stiamo zitti o ciao zia che facciamo
sbarre alle finestre che dici ma non era
questo e lo fa cristo gesù salve
buongiorno mi servirebbero a non capire
come si scappa da qua è via via via via
via via via diana iarc quindi gli altri
sono morti questa dov'è ma che cazzo ci
fa
ahia ahia mi ha preso la spalla non che
cosa mi ha detto sono tutti molto
gentili in questo gioco
allora ce la faccia un maschio ad
ragazzi questo vedo che corre la prima
persona che corre verrà a galla seguendo
i compagni che sono dall'altra parte non
ci sono arrivati non lo so
elena non ti preoccupare che stavolta la
vittoria è nostra me lo sento proprio
qualche bello state facendo
chi ha fede e nifaz ragazzo
socializzando oggi spray ogni somma
nostri aiuti spazio a questi ferito ma
con me ragazzo hanno parlato in inglese
io sono italiani in mezz'ora non capisco
un cazzo che prova a dialogare gate di
you'll find the ashes xix e xxi the
words o figlio o trattati solari spara
le cose belle
ok ragazzo trovato i miei amici
americani gli americani negli horror
selena dammi la mano che questi parlano
traduci farò il corso don ragazzi ho
trovato gli americani e gli americani
film horror non muoiono cioè mai muoiono
mai
dove muoiono pack porca vacca ci ha
visti io scappo di là e io scappo di là
no no no no no porca vacca e lo
sparargli leo sparargli addosso gli
spara addosso ho preso veloce lance
l'agenzia veloce bianche fiscal effetto
è finito l'effetto porca vacca schifoso
non ha fatto a prendermi siano però mi
di tradurre cioè non capisco questi
qualcosa dicono magari mi hanno
insultato la mamma io li capisco
la mia mano di mia fucking and less
reinhard manga and slash reinhard umana
in remember that she sfondamento fatemi
fare il [ __ ] jason per una volta
nella vita a moana pj cava cà sempre
questo boscaiolo schifoso sono vicino
alla macchina ragazzi sono vicino alla
macchina e questo è un ottima news
perché l'ultima volta la zia è riuscito
a preparare la macchina allora abbiamo
bisogno di una tanica della batteria e
niente abbiamo perso ha tra l'altro puoi
parlare con jason scola chat proprio c'è
lui si sente se noi parliamo
sei veramente una [ __ ] facciamo una roba
aiutiamoci a vicenda non fare cagate
riuscire posso seguire io lo seguo la
zia e segue la zia perché lei ne sa e io
no agli one happy hour basse ma come non
era una voce tanto femminile batte you
are a uomo donna because the voce is not
proprio da donna e tanto in york e poi
c'è una voce che portava il mio zio toni
siamo rimasti in quattro meno male che
ci sono riuniti tutti possiamo non si
facciamo pagare lo facciamo tutti
insieme poi soprattutto non so veramente
giocare sta roba
[Musica]
mi sa che ci incula stavolta ragazzi so
sto dubbio mi sa che c ciao zio un
grande usa usa usa la io vi metto sotto
ma che non so cosa succede ma guardo da
qua
[Musica]
[Applauso]
se n'è andato se n'è andata una ragazza
è andato mai bye bye bye bye bye bye
come ho fatto a fuggire che ho fatto a
pulcini relazione a quanto abbiamo
capito jason usa la chat quindi se mi
arriva davanti posso provare a mediare c
visto che io parlo un inglese fluente e
sicuramente sarò in grado di difendervi
verbalmente ma se sfondando cosa e dei
jazz big band o no noi really want liszt
tensioni ventelli di mostri kim jong hun
sen liu jo march gioco che ok tempi
uguali
terni a battisti is not good test the
cat
you are not so simpatico è secondo me va
bene però selena hai visto come si media
con noi killer
hai visto come si tratta di nizza con
nemico se lei non sa bene quindi ragazzo
mogli spero che mi sia piaciuto
[ __ ] a jason non me l'hanno fatto
fare una volta jason si pensi di me ma
anche una però aver agazzi astori vi sia
piaciuto non so di preciso momento è un
mi piace anche i vari social che come di
tradizione
se non si dica che ci vediamo al
prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]